welcome to the kill test
you'll kill
ultimate forged
fire Champion two Champion plays
deadly weapon Showdown it will kill 20
blades 20 Champions you decide the
winner forged in fire Madness
the Mesopotamian sickle sword my name is
Robert Taylor I'm from Brentwood
California I'm a sergeant with the San
Francisco Sheriff's Department I took up
bladesmithing because I'd like to watch
the fortune fire
something I really want to go further in
become an ABS Smith maybe a master smith
someday because I love forging
the sickle sword originated in
Mesopotamia at the height of the Bronze
Age around 2500 BC
these sickle and curved shaped swords
often symbolized royalty and power and
were primarily wielded during ceremonies
by Kings and authority figures although
these swords were not common on the
battlefield the belly of the blade
allowed for quick devastating blows and
inspired designs for later weapons such
as the deadly Egyptian kopech
biggest problem I'm seeing there's a
sharp bend down and then a short sweep
up to a curve so that's going to be hard
to make sure I get the dimensions in
right
Excalibur
it's actually not Excalibur the sword
and the stone is a medieval broadsword
my name is Scott sweeter I am 51 years
old and I am a blacksmith for a living
I love the process of making blades
there is no limit to what you can do
with it it's just your own imagination
the actual Sword in the Stone is located
in Siena Italy believed to have belonged
to Saint galgano Legend has it the
Archangel Michael askalgano to give up
all of his possessions which he argued
would be harder than splitting a stone
to prove his point galgano struck a rock
with his sword which cut through with
ease leaving only the hilt in a few
inches of Blade exposed the sword and
stone is still encased to this day
inside the monosepi chapel while it's
impossible to authenticate the sword's
legendary history recent scientists have
verified that an analysis of the metal
dates back to the 12th century
consistent with the timeline of galgano
back my home Forge gonna be making a
Mesopotamian sickle sword the biggest
build I've done yet I'm doing a thousand
there Sami construction so I'm gonna go
500 layers of Damascus on each side with
a 1084 Center core looking good I'm
doing a thousand there so I want to go
10 times more than I did in round one
all right we're going for our final
Forge weld as long as I'm solid with my
steel 1084 will give a more stronger at
Center I feel pretty good in my progress
oh Forge press that out tomorrow we're
gonna go ahead and feed it over the
Anvil the the place where I want the
bend will bend down and then the tip
will start bending up automatically as I
hit it whacking it on the horn to get it
to bend down it's easier than using the
hammer
I like it got the build all right if the
quench this quench doesn't go right I'm
gonna have to go ahead and start over
that's gonna suck
went in pretty hot
see if we have any bad Forge wields
we have a hard plate I want to keep it
light enough and balanced enough for
somebody to swing it
get in there feel really good about my
weapon
getting all the fit up done I think this
thing's gonna slice anything they put
before it
today I'm making a European broadsword
I'm going to do two types of Twisted
masks going opposite directions and a
linear bar for the center
I am very happy to be back home I know
that I have all the proper tooling do
stuff very quickly
but I think it's going to be a very
challenging competition I got the
Twisted mask is done
I've got to cut them to size and then
clean up the edges that I'm going to
re-weld
that's where it's at right now today's
most important thing is getting that
heat treat done if I can get it done
early I can focus on the handle for the
rest of the build
it's pretty straight in it
definitely hate treated
I'm just going to clamp it while it
cools
I thought I had the heat treat right but
unfortunately after I pull it out it's
got a nice warp in it oh
it looks like I might have to heat treat
again the one difference is I'm going to
use my quench tank as my temporal I'm
going to get the oil up to the same
temperature as I would the oven to about
450 degrees then hold my sword in it for
at least 10 minutes so it gets a nice
soak
foreign
comes out almost perfect all I have to
do is mild is fit and finish guard
handle pump first I need to get the
holes drilled on the guard and the
pommel
and that's all I need it's looking
pretty good
end of day four this Broad Sword is
built and I am ready to go have dinner
with my wife
leachmans welcome to the Keel test
find out what kind of lethal damage they
will do I'm gonna take your weapons
deliver some lethal blows of this
ballistics dummy all right Robert your
turns are you ready I'm ready all right
let's do this
all right Broadway let's talk about your
sickle sword it's a very light blade
that much lighter than the other one and
the angle that you have in here lends
itself to use not only velocity but the
sharpness of your Edge to cut very deep
into this ballistics dummy in overall
sir
he will kill thank you
it's got to your turn sir you ready yes
sir let's do this
I'm ecstatic to see Doug playing with my
sword because it's exciting to see what
it can do to the human body what it's
built for
eign first stop
that is beautiful to look at now the
wire wrap does give me some kind of
Contours to hold on to every slice or
should I say chop dug deep into this
ballistics dummy overall the kind of
weapon and damage you can do with this
it'll kill
thank you
welcome to the strength test the armored
Warrior chop test the strength and
overall durability of your Mesopotamian
sickle swords I'm going to be chopping
into these armored Warriors let's roll
the dice
foreign
good job
well Robert the big thing is it's one
sword nice job thank you
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test now to test the strength
and overall construction of your blades
we have
the battering ram chop
I am very nervous I am very very nervous
I don't know how it's going to do all I
can do is trust that I built it
correctly
so right off scott everything's solid
and tight
all in all I think you did a great job
nicely done thank you
now it's your turn which weapon will you
choose forged in fire Madness